what up everybody i got a king of the
singer for you island boy
because on my island boy
i'm trying to be a island boy
it's the newest song that's hitting the
nation it's a [ __ ] bop
can you understand it gang gang bust
nuts king king the the song sting the
way they look have you seen these dudes
no i don't know what i don't know what
you guys are talking about i'm an island
boy what is this what are you seeing
these two in uh
florida they're definitely florida
material really wait do you see it
they're hawaiian no no that's a hawaiian
song
yeah island
jamaican hitchhikers kind of
no they look like jamaican takashi six
nines yeah that's something i'm out on
white boys with dreads i'm out i don't
think they're wrong they're cuban oh
there you go okay i'm an island boy and
i've been trying to make oh i'm an
island boy
i imma just island boy imma just island
boy
tune oh
if
[Laughter]
if theo's special doesn't like that this
is theo's next move
he already tried this i'm a nashville
boy that's hawaiian what kind of style
is that is that jamaican hawaiian what
is that i couldn't tell ya never heard
that that's their own thing yeah and it
is fire
it's the culture this is cultural
appropriation i feel like yeah
i guess i feel like i like suicide boys
this should just be suicide
these dudes are unbelievable bruh yeah
they're this one happens when y'all
wanted to change the freaking education
system
who are
who are you talking about you got these
white ass freddy douglasses out here
they don't know [ __ ] that's what you got
in this pool right here
i don't i really don't know what this i
feel like an old man yeah i'm old i
don't know what's up
this is just this reminds me of that
little girl who was on like the like uh
dr phil and she was yelling at her
holloway and she was yelling at her
parent her mom and she became a rapper
that baby what's her name baby oh baby
babe
these guys remind me of that catch me
outside girl
yeah yeah
so this is what i'm saying it's the same
kind of thing it's like you kind of hate
listening to this and then and so
they're gonna blow up look we're talking
about it on our part i mean i gotta be
honest i enjoyed it
so you like to hate watch stuff yeah
like i'm not gonna listen to my goddamn
car but it i like that you like the
downfall of society yeah
so that's a king and two stingets and
theo sting the way they look king the
way they sing
i would like to see both of these dudes
fight
nick diaz
that's what i would like and i think he
would do it
uh
i don't know man i don't know what's
going on here i feel like this is a side
effect of something that's happened in
society i think we're going to start
seeing more of it but no that's what
happened when mom when moms vape and
have babies man that's a side effect
that's that great vape right there
they're already tatted they're like 16
years old they're so tattooed on the
chest and you're right they were raised
by their mother their dad died when they
were five
and uh
one of them was asked if he if he wanted
to be a rapper he's like no i never
wanted to be a rapper growing up i just
wanted to be lit oh
and and he's fine
yeah i'd love to see their report cards
you're assuming they're in school yeah
yeah and they don't have more cards
anymore man
they're doing away with those you saw
that in louisiana they just made a law
no more grades that make kids feel bad
that's why i give my kid his own grades
f
keep them humble you know f fine as hell
that little one i know that
what is the peak of these guys's um
career potential you're looking at it
you're looking at it no i totally don't
do a hit single that could be their hits
i think if they like collab with like
takashi six nine dude they would i would
love that if they collab with takashi 69
yeah show it to my dad he just has a
brain aneurysm they just start telling
on people yeah just start snitching just
wondering here's the thing all it takes
is like some
record exec
some money grubbing record exec is gonna
see that and be like oh
get them yeah and then they find some
producer who's got some tracks and they
just let them it's like millie vanilli
man you know they're just gonna have
them do their thing and then the next
thing you know we're gonna be like i
know all people keep saying is why are
these guys famous why are these guys
millions of millions and they don't it
don't even matter
i'm about to sign the thick boy records
i already got little brows
with them in little brows you might have
to fight uh kodak black just reached out
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
is
[Music]